foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing new secret details recently
released regarding the upcoming Harry
Potter game Hogwarts Legacy on September
30th the Hogwarts Legacy Twitter tweeted
the following it's time to bend the
rules and learn some tips not included
in your Field Guide here's an
unauthorized guide to Student Life at
Hogwarts hashtag Hogwarts Legacy and
while many fans at first taught this
guide was some sort of secret guide
perhaps written by a Hogwarts student
in-game it turns out that was wrong pink
Ravenclaw tweeted wait is the
unauthorized guide the field guide or
are those two distinct books to which
Avalanche software Community manager
Chandler wood responded the unauthorized
guide is our fun social spin on things a
fun way to show you a variety of things
around Hogwarts via arms social channels
the field guide is in game with more
details about it yet to be revealed the
regular Field Guide differs from the
unauthorized Field Guide in that it is
an actual usable item within Hogwarts
Legacy whereas the unauthorized version
is simply a bit of social media fun but
for now let's jump back to the
unauthorized Field Guide where
developers have released a number of
secret tips related to the game hidden
Within These tips are many previously
unknown tidbits about the game that fans
should be pleasantly surprised by tip
number one common room secrets Hogwarts
is full of secrets the common rooms are
no exception there's also faded looking
handwriting which seems to say something
to the effect of take staircase to
Kitchen go down hallway third Barrel
this is of course in reference to the
entrance of the Hufflepuff common room
which we've already seen in the common
room tour videos also released by
developers tip 2 Restricted Section of
the library restricted is just a
suggestion but don't get caught
The Faded handwriting on this page reads
bring flowers to garlic or maybe Garrick
make sure they're not wilted I'm not
entirely sure what this one is trying to
communicate but I'd imagine it could be
something to do with Sebastian salo's
storyline and his family curse it could
also be something related to the
Hogwarts librarian tip 3 defense against
the dark arts classroom the classroom
was made for Mischief like meddling with
Professor hackett's hebridian black
skeleton skeleton is circled here for
some reason the faded handwriting on
this page appears to show four spells
including petrificus totalus the full
body bind curse Rick December the
tickling charm ridiculous a Bogut
counter charm and Superfly a stunning
spell four more spells that we now know
will appear in game tip 4 peeves avoid
peeves at all costs The Faded
handwriting on this page says ask about
sharps or a badge this is of course a
reference to Hogwarts Legacy potions
Professor sharp I guess he's an exorer
if you didn't know auras are essentially
law enforcement workers for the ministry
of magic tip 5 secret crossed ones and
just before what appears to be dueling
Club is written everything gets crossed
out for some reason whatever it means
this does confirm that the game will
have a dueling club which is great news
for all tip 6 zonko's joke shop zonkos
is your One-Stop shop for causing Mayhem
and Mischief what this confirms is that
players will be able to visit zonko's
joke shop where they can purchase
materials to prank other students
sometimes you just have to think to
yourself what would Fred and George Do
The Faded enigmatic looking handwriting
on this page says cauldron cakes batter
is moist good to trade with fizzing
wisbees very sweet pepperimps strong
peppermints lets you breathe fire if you
don't remember Ron Weasley discusses
fizzing whispies in the Goblet of Fire
where he describes them as massive
sherbet balls that make you levitate a
few inches off of the ground it's also
worth noting that Albus Dumbledore used
fizzing wisby as the password to his
office in December 1995. tip 7 Forbidden
Forest sneak off in the Forbidden Forest
and live to tell the tale what this
confirms is that players will be able to
access the mysterious Forbidden Forest
located on the Hogwarts grounds The
Faded enigmatic looking handwriting on
this page says mooncalf instructions
brush once a day feed Moon cough a day
with something don't forget playtime
this is likely a reference to the
player's ability to raise different
animals in game this feature will allow
players to channel their inner Newt
commander and to take care of all sorts
of interesting magical creatures and
that's it for now stay tuned for more
Hogwarts Legacy videos and other videos
and be on the lookout for Hogwarts
Legacy giveaway in the near future if
you don't want to miss it be sure to
subscribe until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]